thank you Michael it's a pleasure to be
back here when you and I were visiting
here for two years back in 2010 I'm
assuming most of the people in this room
were not here at the time we had a great
time here at Stanford and it's been the
source of a inspiration and some of the
work that we're talking about today and
some of the work that Wendy told about
it also was made possible by by our
visit here so this is a bold title and
essentially what I wanted to do is to
try to explain why I think it's
important to have more theory in HCI and
how we could go about doing this so to
do this let me just try to put some
context we all use graphical user
interfaces they're still the dominant
way in which we do serious stuff and
computers they were born not far from
here
about four years ago and in four years
they haven't changed well it's not quite
true they got in color but the basic
principles of these interfaces which
were built for essentially secretaries
doing office work are still with us when
we use computers for many many different
things now of course we've seen other
styles of interaction become widespread
widespread like touch based but we don't
do that much with touch we consume media
we tap text messages and things like
this
when these showed in the seminar and on
the Wednesday that you could do much
more but still it's it's kind of a
limited type of medium at the moment
then we've seen over the past few years
voice based interaction also becoming
quite mainstream how many of you
interact at least once a day
with one of this voice assistant okay
now for those of you who are doing say
PhD would you write your dissertation
we're using Alex alone I don't know I
don't think so so they're very good at
some things and maybe not appropriate
for everything same thing can be said
for virtual reality there are many
interesting uses of VR
it's not something that you going to use
for every task you should ask yourself
from the course of the day how many
things I am doing with a computer I
could do better with the VR system and
then in HCI literature we talk a lot
about other styles augmented reality
tangible interaction and bought-in
interactions etc etc and oftentimes all
these styles they are sold to the
readers or to the wider public as
they're going to be the next big thing
they're going to replace gooeys we're
going to get rid of these computers on
our desktops and of course I think this
is just not true these computers will
stay they have good reasons for being
the way they are and so the real
question I think is how can we combine
these different styles of interaction
right now they're sort of developed
independently of each other and in a
sense in competition with each other you
know I'm better at you doing this task
with that task and therefore I don't
need this other style of interaction so
there's the field of multimodal
interaction is trying to combine these
different styles together but we don't
see it an impact yet of these things at
least not widespread so why is that well
I think we've come up to build a digital
world that is very fragmented it's made
of this walled gardens and these
information silos that trap our data
trap our trap ourselves inside
applications so that it is difficult to
in fact combine things and take
advantage of different capabilities in
different environments and the thing is
I don't think it has to be the case I
mean if you look historically look at
email I mean I can be on Gmail and you
can be on the outlook and maybe your
grandmother is still on AOL if it still
exists we can use different mail readers
we can still communicate with each other
because mail was specified as a Protocol
SMTP if you speak SMTP you can do email
but what we have these days is a bunch
of applications services social media
and others the
force you inside their own what they
call ecosystem so you can only go on
Facebook with a Facebook website or the
Facebook application Twitter for awhile
I had an API so there were a bunch of a
Twitter clients and then they shut down
the API because they wanted to control
the whole user experience
same thing with files it used to be the
case that everything was an ASCII file
and I could use any kind of editor to
edit my files and then proprietary
formats and and applications came up and
that was locked inside maybe Microsoft
Office suite or another one and now it's
even worse because I have the cloud and
I don't even own my files they are
floating somewhere around I don't know
what the the cloud services do with it
in fact in France we are not supposed to
use Google Drive we're not supposed to
use Skype because we don't know exactly
what's happening with all all the data
there and if you look again in the past
in UNIX you could build your own tools
using pipes and basic constructs to
assemble little pieces into bigger
bigger scripts and applications but
these days we're given apps that do a
bunch of things more and more we are
required to do updates so we don't
control even the functionality more and
more we are subscribing to automatic
updates so they change every morning
maybe and the result of that is there's
no interest in becoming an expert
because it can be an expert in Photoshop
six point six and then one day version
seven comes up and things have changed
so I think this fragmentation did not
have to to be it creates a lack of
flexibility people have to use the
applications to where they are given the
services the way they are designed
they cannot appropriate their tools they
cannot create their own environment as
easily as we can do in the physical
world and to take an expression from
when the software is not soft
very rigid in fact and so I think that
we need to break out of this model I
think one app is not enough to deal with
one type of content I think one device
is not enough when we juggle between
smartphones and tablets and other
devices and it's so hard to manage
content across these devices one user is
not enough when everything we do almost
is collaborative and what I mean here is
not the kind of sharing we see on on
social media where you you know take a
selfie and and then distribute copies
around that you lose control over I'm
talking about real sharing of digital
content now all of these analysis led me
to create a project that I called one
which is the acronym of one is not
enough and yes I'm proud of that but the
reason it's called one is because my
goal was to say well can we identify
principles that have sort of wide range
to be applied to different styles of
interaction to break these barriers
between applications between devices
between services and this project was
funded by the European Research Council
and the goal here or rather the argument
is that to support the diversity to
support interoperability we need
unification we need underlying first
principles if you wish so what we want
is to support interoperability we want
to support end-user appropriation we
want to create a digital world that is
flexible in ways that it is rarely seen
today and the question here is then how
do we identify these principles where do
they come from my argument here is that
they come from looking at underlying
theories theories of HCI
theories that series of human-computer
interaction theories that are relevant
to the phenomena that we study now to
try to put this bit into perspective
because of course I'm had the first one
to talk about theory in HCI and there's
been a lot of work that has been done I
will again refer to to went his work and
a paper I encourage everyone to read
from 1997 with no fire which was called
I think triangulation across disciplines
where they looked at the role of theory
in different disciplines so in Natural
Science you have the real world the
physical world or the phenomena you
observe and then you build and refine
theories now in some Sciences you start
from theory and then you try to validate
it through experiments in other fields
you tend to start with observations and
then you create frameworks and then you
refine them through new observations in
both cases you have this back and forth
where theory gets refined according to
successive observations but in HCI like
in other fields of engineering in
particular we're not just observing a
world that is there before us we also
create this world we create artifacts in
this world and so when you create
artifacts the role of theory and
observation changes a little bit you can
create artifacts based on empirical
observation to address some specific
problems you can see in a particular
field to have an object that we solve
this problem and artifact can also be
inspired by theory now I think if you
look at the way this works out in HCI
what I'm looking for is generative
theory and to explain what I mean by
that
let me try to draw the the contrast here
in HCI we have a lot of design methods
if you take a child
you've learned about things like
prototyping like conducting interview
like maybe participatory design like
brainstorming like paper prototyping I
think I would argue that all these
design methods are really bridging the
gap if you wish between observations you
can make in the real world and the
artifacts you're building and this is
all nice and good and it's very
efficient but we're still missing the
link with theory up there and for me the
linguist theory comes when you try to
take existing theories because there are
a lot of relevant theories in in
psychology and sociology and
anthropology etc and you try to make
them not only relevant but also to
operationalize them for HCI to take
abstract principles like I don't know
distributed cognition what does it mean
to apply that to the design of an HDI
artifact so when we talk about
generative theory and generative
principles they're not generative in the
sense that I push a button and something
comes out of it there are generative in
the sense that they they sort of
influence designer to be more creative
to have more possibilities to explore so
we call this bridge between theory and
and design design principles and some
people have said well this is a
misleading term so sometimes you call
them generative principles and other
people aren't happy so the point is I
want to make theory more effective so
the rest of this talk will present two
examples of this one slightly long and
the other shorter but I wanted to
illustrate it through two very different
sets of theories so the first example is
about drawing from theories of human
tool use now when we interact in the
world in the physical world we can do it
through language I can
asked you to take notes or to get me a
bottle of water so this is voice
mediated interaction but we also do a
lot of things with our hands and with
our bodies through physical action and
these actions are often mediated by
tools in fact there are many things we
do we couldn't do without tools
those of you taking notes on paper use a
pen we have tools for drawing or cooking
for woodworking for moving ourselves etc
in fact human tool use is can be traced
back 3.3 million years we've found
records of manmade tools rocks been cut
to become weapons more than three
million years ago and the history of
mankind is really linked to creating
tools to creating tools to create more
tools to teaching how to create tools
and to solve a lot of problems through
appropriate tools and and you know
Industrial Revolution is one example the
printing press is another one but every
step along the way you can find the use
of tools in human evolution so the
theories I'm using here to try to
translate this knowledge we have from
human to use into HCI come from
psychology the first one is the theory
of affordances from William Gibson I'm
assuming you all familiar with
affordances how many of you have read
Gibson yeah well the other ones you know
what you have to do now the notion of
affordance is very powerful because it
says that there are properties in the
world in the objects in the world in the
environment relative to the subject to
the animal in general but women that
supports certain activities so if you
see this person and this big object
because of their relative size it will
have a certain number of affordances
that they wouldn't have if the subject
would be an elephant or would be an ant
now there's a foreign since you don't
have to perceive them and that's where
there is a big misunderstanding in the
HCI community about affordances that you
perceive versus those you don't perceive
and I think the missing bit is the work
of Eleanor Gibson and the fact that her
last name is Gibson isn't an accident
because they were married but HCI has
sort of forgotten the woman one more
time and she studied developmental
psychology she's famous for this
experiment of the visual cliff showing
that kids a few a couple months old
understand that they shouldn't walk
beyond the border of a table even if
here you have a glass so in fact the
glass supports the weight and the kid
could cross but he has learned that when
there is a visual cliff you should not
go over and so other Gibson's notion of
perceptual learning says that we
perceive to learn and we learn to
perceive and that bridges the gap
between affordances of husband of James
Gibson and I think the stuff we talked
about in HCI because we need to
recognize affordances to recognize the
capabilities of objects of entities
whether they're physical or digital now
at the level of tool use itself there
are a number of well they're not that
many actually theories around to use but
the one I've been inspired by is by this
French and neuroscientist Francoise
Jacques who's connected studies where is
looking at people with different forms
of apraxia brain damage in general that
makes them unable to for example use
tools for what they are designed for and
so it's come up with the theory of
technical reasoning that says that when
you don't have pre-existing knowledge of
how a particular tool can solve a
particular problem you run simulations
in your head and you look at the
relationships between the tool or the
you're going to use as a tool and your
hand on the one hand and the
relationship between that tool with the
object of interest that you want to
manipulate on the other hand and you see
if things match and that's how you
realize that if you need to in screw it
screw but you don't have a screwdriver
you can use a knife or if you need to
stir your coffee but you don't have a
spoon you can use the the handle of the
hand of the handle of the of the fork
etc and we do this all the time we
always appropriate objects we always
take objects and use them for things
they were not designed for and this
mediation by tools is very powerful in
fact there is evidence that in the brain
we have for example neurons that detect
which objects are accessible without
having to reach out to check if they are
indeed accessible it turns out that if
you put a stick in my hand and therefore
I have a wider reach those neurons will
fire now for the objects that become
accessible through the stick so the tool
becomes an extension of my body so as
this is a very powerful concept and you
know you can look at how kids are able
to appropriate things to paint on walls
for example and it inspires me to say
well can we use this capabilities we
have that we are not necessarily
completely aware of but we use
spontaneously in the digital world and
that's where things become a little bit
complicated because in fact the physical
world is very flexible if I show you
this images you're going to see a pencil
you gonna see a mug but in a different
context the pencil will become a ruler
because it is rigid it is thin it is
straight you can carry it etc etc the
mug will become a paperweight so you
appropriate properties of an object that
may not be relevant necessarily for this
object intended use but that are
relevant to the use at hand but when you
go to digital this is nothing happen
this is a word processor it's there to
process and layout words
and that's all it will do it won't let
you do this kind of word processing
where you write annotations in won't let
you write music it certainly won't let
you do paper airplanes so digital
objects are created for particular
purpose and they are stuck with that
purpose now there are a few exceptions
spreadsheets are an exception
spreadsheets have been appropriated in
many many ways here we see a
visualization of the New York
electricity consumption animated Ninja
Turtles in Excel yes
some kind of game here with complex
rules done also in a spreadsheet but if
you think about it there are very few
example where you have this level of
creativity from the tool that was
designed to essentially calculate the
sums of columns of numbers so we have
this big gap between physical and
digital tools you look at the desktop of
a graphic designer you have all these
tools that he has picked himself because
they fit his way of working and they are
organized in his desk maybe it looks
messy but I'm sure it's meaningful for
him and then you go to the tools we have
in computers and there are the same for
everyone so that led me to try to
explore this notion of bringing the
notion of instrument to digital
interaction in the same way that we have
physical tools that mediate interaction
like the pencil lets me leave marks and
pieces of paper so I can write can we
have the equivalent in the digital world
can we have digital tools now we have
tools that are actually specific of the
digital world the scroll bar I don't
know an equivalent of the scroll bar in
the physical world it was invented for
the computer when we decided that
instead of having pages documents could
be as long as we wanted the scroll bar
here is what I call the reification it
turns
a function that we needed to operate on
the digital content which was to make
the invisible parts visible this
scrolling operation into an object
called the scroll bar and I think this
is what happens in the physical world
where we appropriate an object to do
something here it was designed for this
purpose but we see in a number of
interfaces a lot of examples where
people have taken inspiration from this
tool based interaction for example in
drawing tools but also in this more
physical interaction with the Wiimote
where you can actually buy these
contraptions here to turn your Wii mode
into a tennis racket or or a golf club
to sort of bring some of the qualities
of these of these tools to the
interactions that that you're doing okay
so I've started with this notion of
human tool use talked about a little bit
the theory of human to use trying to
bring that to the digital world now what
is this principles that are going to
bridge the gap between the theory that
is quite abstract and the artifacts that
we're trying to build well the first one
is rafe occation and I already mentioned
it I think this is the most powerful one
that we found so far we've used it with
our students for many many years and it
triggers solutions that they wouldn't
have otherwise thought about so here is
a first example where we want to take a
function that you find in many drawing
tools PowerPoint illustrator etc which
is aligning objects I'm sure you will
all struggle with these dialog boxes
where you need to select a bunch of
things and you hit the button and then
everything is stacked on top of each
other and you say no I need to n do and
try another one now this is a command
approach this is not an instrument this
is not a tool what would be a tool to
align objects well if you want
objects on on the desk for example you
can take a ruler and push the objects
and it will all get aligned so we
created this thing called magnetic guide
lines so magnetic guide lines I'll in
the video it's a line you can attach
objects to it they snap and then guess
what you move the line and the objects
move with it now you've seen that once
you understand how it works if it's a
distribution line it distributes objects
and if you remove them at them the
distribution adjust accordingly if you
put the line in the right position it
will snap everything at once you can of
course snap to multiple lines and it
does the right thing you can also move
the line and sort of grab objects as you
go the system can actually also give you
feed forward about possible alignments
and then it will create the lines if you
drop the object at that position and
then you can manipulate the alignment
and then we can push this further
alignment sometimes it's not visually
satisfying so here we are tweaking using
the arrow keys I'm actually cheating
with the alignment reference but this
tweak itself is an object I can select
it copy it paste it and now this object
has the same tweak same correction to
its visual alignment and if I don't need
it anymore I can remove it I can tweak
the center of the object I can also
tweak its bounding box again
so I reconcile the visual weight of the
object with its geometric bounds and
again I can copy it I can paste it I can
here adjust it in that case and this is
particularly useful when you are dealing
with distribution these objects they are
evenly distributed from the point of
view of the system but they are not from
the point of view of the designer
because his bounding box is not visually
accurate now by adjusting the bounding
box now I have a reasonable distribution
and then we can go even further if we
can align things on
I probably can do it in circles and
other shapes I can align things around
an existing object like this disk here
and I could change the diameter of
course of the of the circle I can align
on arbitrary lines and finally I believe
I can for distribution lines I can
change the rule of distribution I can
make it so they are more sparsely
distributed in the middle than on the
sides now all of these possibilities
came out of one idea take this notion of
alignment turn it into an object and see
how far we could push it now the second
principle that we've found very powerful
is polymorphism in the physical world
objects have capabilities that can be
applied to things of different types in
computers it's usually not the case one
of our favorite example is the color
palette if you go into Microsoft Word
you have in fact within word I think
there were three or four different color
palettes that are all slightly different
but then you move to photoshop and then
you have another one and then if you
want to use a very different type of
palette that these painters like palette
or if you want to use this device that
can actually pick colors in the physical
world through a sensor you cannot bring
that to your environment so we worked
with graphic designers and we looked at
how they work with colors and we created
a set of what we call probes technology
probes to show how we could make they're
dealing with color more meaningful and
computers like they compared to what
they do today so here this replaces the
swatches of colors that you have in many
tools you can actually resize and
reorganize the swatches so that you can
see how the contrast between colors
works out and how they work in real in
relationship to each other rather than
just next to each other as
we have in in current tools very simple
idea
another example here is how to yes
designers play with color they they
explore they want to explore color
palettes they have all sorts of
processes for doing this and so we
created the system that actually where
the system is actually an active partner
that proposes colors depending on how
far you are clicking from existing color
swatches these colors that are suggested
by the system you see they disappear
progressively except if you click on it
because you like it in which case it
stays there and so again through this
exploration of turning a simple
operation like color picking into a
selection collection of tools we can
empower designers with many more
possibilities there's a third principle
that I won't have time talk about today
it's called reuse we spend a lot of time
reusing stuff we've done we're doing
stuff the same way with different types
of content and we think that the history
of your interaction should be an object
first-class object that should be able
to manipulate and and reuse what I want
to talk about is that the sort of the
dual part of instruments I've talked
about tools an instrument that operate
on stuff what is the stuff they operate
on what we call that information
substrates and the word substrates is
convenient because it's used in many
areas for many different things it can
be the substrate for a plant that
provides its you know nourishing
environment it can be a substrate in
material engineering with information
substrates we think more of things like
a structure that organizes contents so
these little dots here I know there are
music notes because they're on the staff
if there were just this dots on paper
without any other structure I wouldn't
know what they are so substrates can be
very organized
they may look disorganized like this
tool pallet although I'm sure the
painter did that it has meaning for for
it 9
we have already this notion of
substrates or at least we can analyze
existing software as such I mentioned
the spreadsheet earlier spreadsheet has
its underlying relationships this graph
of dependencies to me this is a
substrate it's what gives the power to
the to the spreadsheet actually in tools
like Photoshop you have all these layers
that desires learn to manage to create
complex complex effects so substrate is
something that combines structure the
content relative to that structure with
a set of rules to organize this content
to add constraints to this content to
map this content to other substrates and
to other element and the idea here is to
replicate the fact that in the physical
world when we look at an object it is
often used for its properties not its
intended use
so this pencil here is made of atoms and
molecules and a material that is
flammable so you could burn it if you
need it it's also sturdy and straight so
you can use it as a ruler so it's an
object it's also a tool for particular
purpose it also has maybe cultural value
etc so objects physical objects are
exist at sort of different levels of
other if I want to say abstraction but
there would be a computer science term
for it and so with substrates we want to
do the same thing if you see a graph on
your screen
you know once it's on your screen it's a
set of pixels but those pixels they are
actually shapes like this histogram made
of rectangles and this shape is a
visualization of a particular graph
which is itself a visualization of part
of a table now when you see the pixels
in a sense you see everything that's
underneath it in that diagram or if you
don't see it literally it is there and
so you have different objects that can a
different tool sorry that can act as the
different different levels I can paint
pick
I can change the color of these
rectangles I can change the type of the
graph I can change the values in the
table and these are very specific tools
that could apply to other types of
substrates for different types of
content and so if we manage to have an
environment where these representations
are explicitly linked to each other I
think we can create instrumental
interfaces that are pretty powerful so
here's an example again that we did
again with graphic designers where we
were looking at how they design the
layout complex layouts in books and
other objects and we gave them tools
where they could actually a little bit
like a spreadsheet approach to layout
where they could create simple formulas
linking things like the position of of
these different elements on the screen
or their font size or different visual
elements so that for example the layout
would change according to the size of
the text and the time of day or other
elements and that led them reflect in
their design the ideas they had in their
mind which they are not able to do with
current tools current tools they have to
sort of pre pre calculate everything and
then sort of implement it in HTML or
whatever with this tool they could
actually enact directly in the tool the
rules that they had in mind now the last
principle in this example in an example
of two leaders I won't talk about is
sharing I think we all like Google Docs
or share leg or over leaf now because it
gives us this ability to really share
digital content in real time but these
tools they suffer from the prom I
mention that you are trapped in overleaf
and in fact when my next guide papers in
overleaf
I cannot edit it if I'm offline because
probably things get will get lost and I
have to use the overleaf editor I cannot
use my favorite sublime editor for
example
so what if we supported Universal
sharing sort of the ability to share
content an instrument like independent
of the notion of application so this is
what we did with the system called web
straights so in websites you edit a page
in the web and you can see in real time
a different representation just by
changing the stylesheet and you see this
and this can be you know among different
users here we see a figure being drawn
on a tablet it's showing up on that
laptop where it's going to redraw it
with SVG so to have structure graphics
but we also see it in content in the
tablet there in the context of the of
the paper through what's called
transclusion which was a concept
invented by Ted Nelson here we have a
tool called a citation tool so that if I
write a keyword I can then look up a
database a bib tag database here
references turn that keyword into a
reference at the reference at the end of
my paper all this with one click now the
thing is that this tool is itself just a
piece of HTML and JavaScript so I can
actually copy it I can share the editor
of my partner there paste that tool in
there and then that other person has a
site tool at the top right there and can
use it so there's no distinction between
the content the paper I'm writing and
the tools I'm using to edit that content
that makes for very powerful
combinations and I'm gonna skip over
that video then we go into a different
type of content editor which is for
slides and here the site tool that I had
in the other system can be pasted there
as well and works the reference is added
in the last slide of the of the
presentation but more interestingly is
when I go to ya the conference session
where I can have my
presenter notes in one particular web
straight different from the slides being
viewed fullscreen the audience can have
access to my slide but in a web straight
where they have a way to write a
question those questions get collected
onto a different web straight that the
conference the session share can can see
you can select some of the questions and
directly write them on the last slide of
the presentation so that by the time the
presenter comes to the end he sees the
list of questions and this is done
without any magic just a little bit of
JavaScript programming and this idea of
sharing content in real time between
different documents and we'd played with
the tangible stuff as well but you'll
have to see that the full video for this
so in this first example I've tried to
show you how starting from these
abstract theories of our four dances and
human tool use we get to instrument
their interaction and two principles to
enact this notion of instruments into
specific applications but I wanted to
also show you that this process can work
with other types of theories and
including theories that are not
particularly seen as HCI theory so for
as fewers I've been working with a
specialist of information theory Telecom
Harris called Aliyev you'll and we've
had a PhD student together Abbi who's
looked at how information theory can be
used not only as an analysis tool in HCI
but also as a design tool how many of
you know about information theory oh
yeah good I don't get that response in
France I don't know why they don't teach
information theory in CS anymore by
information theory you have an emitter
receiver and they and then you send
information and information can be
distorted or lost in the course of the
transmission and there are some
beautiful mathematical theorems about
maximum capacity and etc so here the
design principle that we wanted to
extract for
the theory is if we consider and I admit
it's a reductive view but if we consider
that when I use a computer part of what
I do is transfer information to the
computer to tell it I want to pick that
file in my file system or I want to go
to that place in my Google Maps now what
I want is this to be as effective as
possible so what I want this to maximum
maximize the amount of information that
I will transfer to the computer even
though the channel may be noisy and that
led to this notion of maximizing
information gain and the framework that
we call big because it using Bayesian
Bayesian approach and so big is the
Bayesian information gain framework so
if you are trying to get to something on
your computer you have a specific target
in mind
we'll call it theta and the system has
some prior knowledge about the
probability that you want may want to
look for each target maybe from prior
usage maybe from other data or if it
doesn't know it will be a uniform
probability meaning it knows nothing now
the goal of the game is the system
starts with a high uncertainty because
it doesn't know which target you want
and the goal is over time to reduce this
uncertainty and what we're going to do
is that the system is going to provide a
view to this to the user we call it
feedback and relative to this view the
user is going to input some command so
I'll show in a moment a map application
you see a view of the map and you want
to go somewhere then the user will input
the command that command will transmit
some information which will reduce the
uncertainty of the system narrowing down
the set of targets that are likely to
the point where you've reached the
target you want now if you want to
maximize information gain here what we
want to do is to affect what input the
user is going to give us by manipulating
the system's output
so depending on what I show you I will
change the probabilities of what you're
going to do next and to maximize
information gain I want to show you
something where the system is the most
uncertain about what you're going to do
next which is counterintuitive because
you have tempted to say well the system
should show you what's most likely but
that's not the most efficient it's most
efficient to show you something where
your next action will give the system
the most information so we do the math
we're not afraid of the Greek letters it
all works out it's computable and here
is a practical application this was
presented at a conference that was in
Denver so we start with your view in
Denver and we want to navigate towards
New York here on the right now this
input we give to the system is very
coarse because it's one of eight
directions or zooming into the middle or
clicking the target if it's in sight
so here I mean Denver I want to go
towards New York so I want to go east
that's all I say now the system is going
to assume that if I want to go is East
my target is towards the east although
there is a user behavior function that
says I'm 5% of the time I may make an
error so don't completely omit the
targets on the left because maybe it was
a mistake so we can model the the user
behavior in that way then again we do
the math I'm not gonna go into details
and then the system has to pick the next
view now it could give you a new view
with all four big cities on the right or
one of the smaller one or something in
between now intuitively you may think
well I want to show the big view because
that's where my target is most likely to
be but this is not what the system is
doing what the system is doing is
showing you this because it doesn't know
any which of these four targets you may
want to go to so by giving you this view
there is approximately equal chances
that you want to go left towards Kansas
City right towards New York or zoom in
to go to Chicago or Washington and
because there is this maximal
uncertainty whichever input you will
give it will give the system more
information now we apply this to actual
map navigation and we found that the
users the participants in the study were
four times as 40% sorry not four times
forty up to 40% faster at navigating in
this system as they were with a
traditional pan and zoom
the only problem though is and you may
see that this is another example where
we are going to Helsinki the way the
system reacts to your commands may not
be intuitive because you may say go into
that direction and the system will do
something slightly different so there is
a usability issue here of how to
reconcile the fact that the system is in
a sense challenging you and the fact
that you want to anticipate what the
system is going to do and that's an
interesting question to address but the
last point I wanted to make before
concluding here was that we've applied
this exact same approach to file
navigation with a slightly different
interface it had a static part which was
traditional file navigation and then the
part at the top where the system would
give you the various choices selected
with the same method and again in that
interface we found up to 40% gain in
performance when people were using the
adaptive sorry the adaptive interface
okay so in the in this project what
we're trying to do is to create a set of
concepts through understanding
interaction given various theoretical
frameworks to conceptual modeling to
turn these theories into actual designs
to system exploration to value
date those designs I've introduced the
notion of substrate of instruments
there's another layer called
environments that I don't have time to
talk about where we're trying to
integrate all of these bricks all these
pieces together into full fledge
environment that combines large wall
size displays together with
collaborative interaction together with
tangible interaction for the video sorry
together with co-located collaboration
this is very dark where people can throw
things at each other etc defining new
tools and instruments for these types of
environments to collaboration that can
be not only within one environment but
across environments or remote
collaboration across walls as displays
and interactive environment and so try
to bridge the gap from the building
blocks of interaction to full fledge
environments to conclude I think in a
sense this is nothing more than trying
to realize in our own way the division
of Doug Engelbart of augmenting human
intellect of creating tools that will
help people be more creative solve
bigger problems and deal with more
challenging issues I have usually around
here against AI and how AI is these days
trying to take you a different route by
trying to say that we're going to do
everything for you and turn us into
these people this is from the movie
wall-e where the humans they have
escaped the the earth or sitting in this
ship where everything is automated and
they spend alive their lives or watching
videos and and drinking coca-cola this
is my vision of what the
human-in-the-loop approach that we hear
a lot about is is is getting into making
us cogs in the machine where it's Dai
doing everything for us and we are just
here to provide the input to the machine
learning algorithms I think there's
other ways to use AI and
Stanford there's a human centered AI
Institute or whatever is the exact name
in Europe there is a project called you
mean a I that is I think starting and
and and I think there is a realization
that we can create systems where it's
more the computer in the loop where
those systems those tools that we create
with computers can enable us to do more
things rather than doing things in our
place and with that I'll stop here and
be happy to answer if you have any
questions
[Applause]